right off the bat I can't help but
notice these globs of what looks like a
cheese poop I guess that's why they call
it poutine ladies and gentlemen who is
gonna take home before in this week's
episode of EVs watch we have two
contestants here from different parts of
North America
here to compete for the glory of the
golden spork two people come in two
meals are swapped but only one can win
today we are swapping fries I'm
representing the Philly Jersey Delaware
area with some disco fries these don't
look like traditional disco fries disco
fries are supposed to have gravy on them
and some like sprinkle cheese I guess
these will do for today disco fries to
me or god it's so nostalgic basically
when you grow up in an area where diners
are on every street corner you go with
your friends when you're sixteen to a
diner and you just get the cheapest
thing on the menu which is disco fries
they're pretty much like a poor man's
poutine so so I represent in Canada we
have Poots in and it's from Quebec so
and again puts in Putin puts in good
tene is the English version but I've
been so used to say the French wipe that
puts in
yes there you go educating everyone
today so this is pretty similar to a
disco fries as fries and what's a
difference is that there's cheese curds
and the word cheese curd sounds gross
but if you say in French it's nicer
homage ankh I know it's like that again
imagine Chi Y Maj I'm going to claim
green okay okay yeah so it's like grain
of cheese and so it's like little clumps
of cheese that's very like chewy and
like squeaky when you put in your mouth
because they're fresh if you put in the
fridge it like absorbs all the moisture
so it comes really hard so it has to be
fresh and then you melt it with like hot
gravy it's just a beautiful combination
so this is very common in Canada I'm
from Montreal so it's like in the
province of Quebec and same thing like
it's a great hangover food or like after
like a night out let me tell you
something about disco fries once you
have them you
want any other cheese fries forget it
chili cheese fries absolutely not
nacho fries no don't even think about it
disco fries you get potato you get the
gravy you get the cheese you understand
but you don't get that squeak what's
that squeaks cheese curd gets hard it
absorbs the moisture in the fridge
sounds like bacteria place that I wanna
be I think this is gonna win because
once you've tried cheese curd
that's squeak in your mouth you can't go
back like she said it's the poor man's
version of the service oh this is like a
classic the one thing that you should
try most of us are poor though so we
found some gravy
so now I think we have a much better
chance of winning and it smells pretty
good it really does it does I'm a little
nervous
let's do it enjoy you as well right off
the bat I can't help but notice these
globs of what looks like a cheese poop I
guess that's why they call it poutine
I'm excited to try it I mean it smells
like french fries and cheese and gravy
so there's no reason why this shouldn't
taste good well I'm the Canadian so I
can't help but be nice this presentation
is really beautiful with the gravy and
the parsley it just adds a nice little
touch thumbs up is there a way to stay
in English Bon Appetit but like the
English way you know I'm words for
anything okay so I'm trying to make a
cheese pull that's kind of clumpy again
being nice if it was a little bit more
heated it'd be a nicer cheese pull I'm
not getting a squeaks I know squeak
these curds I will say these aren't
these are really tasty though the gravy
is really good the cheese kind of tastes
like a mild watered-down mozzarella
maybe it's not really doing it for me
I don't really taste the cheese because
the gravy is so flavorful but I could
feel the cheesiness in my mouth but the
cheese doesn't have any distinctive
flavor but the gravy very good got some
neutral cheese's here I like that you
can kind of get one with every bite but
it I want to be able to mix it all up
kind of like you can with those guys
this is kind of like you have to piece
it together I get enough at it I'm like
a salad it's like a french fries salad I
do see your point of how it's like
everything's already like mixed together
but the only thing is when everything is
melted it kind of feels like
a big clump when I tickets all like
together so it's really hard for me to
just like eat it we're not cute over
there in the tri-state area this is
really similar to the Canadian version
so yeah I feel like if I missed home and
I wasn't in Canada and I was like in New
York or New Jersey I would totally go
for disco fries because it's the same it
just reminds me of home it's close
enough
well I want to try those things so try
to scrapie so good I pumped immediately
my face changed I'm really happy
there's a bit of a squeak it feels more
fresh it would really feel a squeak but
I can imagine it she's imagining the
squeak it's not there this is like disco
fries served at an Italian restaurant
this gravy tastes very like it's got a
bunch of oregano in it it's almost like
a pasta sauce it's really tasty it's not
quite it I would say that's more like
gravy in my mind
yeah really more thicker like yeah
almost a sick-ass soup I feel like you
should just try this one more time the
cheese now that you've compared that
cheese though this cheese okay there's
just more like personality to the cheese
that little guy right there
yeah you're right
got more personality poutine was very
good cheese curds tasted really great
just go fries little disappointing not
the Jersey Philly diner way I did really
like my experience with disco fries I
would be curious to try DSN tick 1/2 - I
love the name disco fries but at the
other day my heart goes to puts in
because it's the cheese yeah the Irish
tray that's true we have come to a final
decision Canada I'm sorry the US but
another dog went cheap tuition for
school we have free health care nature
fresh air puts in and William and I want
to share this because Canadians are nice
you see this look at us I love Canada
we didn't be friends that's all yeah
people who eat disco fries this is
devastating please help me describe how
just amazing they are
comments please puts in lovers you need
the tried disco fries try the cousin
version of boots in because that's great
as well but idea today Canadians win the
squeak the squeak yes cheesecake squeak
don't don't be afraid of the names
cheese curds remember for all mankind
so to go home as okay one more time
homage on guy great
[Music]